rêvons un peu je crois que c'est
nécessaire après un tel reportage
reviendrait vont un peu avec la sortie
du guide michelin
1989 la bible des gastronomes discrétion
efficacité
ces jugements sont rarement démentie le
guide sorti pour la première fois
gratuitement en 1900 à 35 mille
exemplaires il est aujourd'hui vendu à
720 mille exemplaires pour le premier
tirage cette année une seule troisième
étoiles le maximum en europe pour le
restaurant le crocodile à strasbourg
propriétaire est cuisinier emilio
où j'ai très connu le guide il figurait
en bonne place c'est-à-dire par des des
toilettes une consécration leur nombre
est sévèrement contrôlé même s'il n'y a
pas de quotas les loups la cuisse vous
paraître un bon film mais chine je crois
que c'est un peu une caricature
inspecteurs michelin anonymes qui doit
rester comme disait de gaulle c'est tout
à fait étonnant beaucoup
convenablement chaussée solitaire vous
accompagnez les inspecteurs prospects
pour eux une seule règle la discrétion
chez leur employeur on a refusé de nous
dire leur nombre mais on nous a affirmé
que ce sont des hommes pour la plupart
et qu'ils ont fait l'école hôtelière
même si l'un d'entre eux vient d'une
école de commerce l'essec
ici à strasbourg l'un de ses inspecteurs
caricaturé par louis de funès est passé
grâce à lui et à d'autres le chef a
obtenu sa troisième étoile récompense
ultime pour un homme qui pense qu'en
employant plus de trois ingrédients dans
un plat en en perles vous car ici la vie
d'un plat est tissée au fil d'or depuis
qu'on l'a annoncé en cuisine le bras est
un outil mais il dépasse il transcende
un savoir-faire il respecte l'esprit de
la cuisine il ne fait que souligner le
goût de ce centre un poisson que n'a
semble-t-il pas manger l'inspecteur
voix tiens monsieur qui est venu qu'à
manger un couteau de truffes l'année
dernière
il était souriant affable je soupçonne
que c'était un inspecteur du chemin mais
il est venu est parti sans se faire
connaître c'est la série était 23e et
ses mystères
à la table du prince du luxembourg on
accueille avec les égards dus à son rang
1 mais de qualité et si des esprits
chagrins venait à trouver qu'il y a
quelque chose d'injuste à faire une
cuisine inaccessible à la plupart
d'entre nous il aurait raison ils
peuvent aussi regretter de ne pouvoir
s'offrir la joconde pour leur salle à
manger aux l'homme